I'm joined here by Joe Shelley who's the
game director for uh Diablo 4 and then I
have uh Joseph pipora who's the
associate game director of uh Diablo 4.
uh obviously this is our like I said our
first live stream here live at blizzard
uh right now that we're doing the cave
live in the cave we're here you guys are
seeing it for the first time this is our
brand new studio uh that we'll be doing
live streams from going forward uh you
probably recognize some familiar things
in the background as well uh we have uh
like bail back here uh from the Diablo 2
resurrected commercial that we actually
did with simu simulu and uh and uh
Winston Duke which is really cool we got
like the giant Diablo School in the
background our our skate deck I'm like
trying to point in random directions
right now as I look at myself on this
monitor yeah and then of course
right here um and what's cool oh and and
behind Joe's head we actually have a a
giant treasure Goblin Treasure Island
it's the mascot oh it's right yeah
sneaking off on her team Diablo there
um especially in our building here at
blizzard um but as you guys know we've
been doing a developer quarterly update
Vlogs uh since the announce uh back in
2019 uh with with Diablo 4 and this is
kind of our new format going forward
we're actually going to be doing more
and more developer update live streams
as we head towards launch uh for D4 and
even post launch but this gives us the
opportunity of being able to connect
with the community uh hear from the dev
straight from them uh through a fun
format like live stream so please excuse
our our mistakes and slip UPS I promise
you we'll have them uh that's the best
part about doing live streams and so
forth um the live part exactly but at
the same time what's great about these
is that you guys will be able to hear
more and more from the developers behind
the scenes and hear their stories about
how they are working on the game and
what they're working on so in future
live streams we'll have more information
and more details about uh Diablo 4
before we head into launch
um but yeah I know we we have a lot of
stuff uh that we actually did announce
uh over the past week and Joe I think it
would be like a great opportunity for us
to kind of uh dive in and and kind of
talk more about like what what's a card
over the past couple weeks yeah the past
couple weeks have been you know really
the culmination of the past year of
getting the game getting all the content
into the game testing the game you know
we've had test after test this year
internal tests uh the closed beta end
game test which was uh you know we
wanted to test our end game to make sure
that uh uh we have a chance to tune it
and polish it before launch yeah better
to better to test it before as early as
possible right
um and uh you know including uh the um
the previous the Press previews that we
that we did uh some of the press got to
play and Community got to play
um a little bit before the game awards
and then of course we had the game
awards moment that uh you know really
capped off the year and uh brought in um
we had the the monks take over uh the
game awards the the there in LA we had
um uh that that wonderful opening where
the everything got dark and it you know
he sort of had a little bit of mystery
about what was going to happen and then
of course Halsey uh performing yeah the
the Halsey moment was was uh amazing uh
and this this image was so cool this is
uh actually a a picture she ended up uh
taking right before the game Awards
performance uh holding the Diablo skull
uh
incredibly
like iconic in terms of how it was it
was fantastic I had no idea she was a
huge Diablo fan I mean I love how it
mirrors this the statue of Lois holding
the Diablos yes yeah yeah and she is a
huge Diablo fan she you know she she
said she her first Diablo game was
actually D2 uh so it's it's pretty cool
to to be working with her and having her
perform her song Lilith uh there uh at
the game awards and having that cool
moment as we led into uh you know the
the reveal of the trailer and of course
you know the big announcements at the
game awards being uh the release date uh
for Diablo 4 which is we can finally say
that's right which is June 6 2023 uh and
uh during that uh you know announcement
we also ended up opening up pre-orders
uh for the game uh and we have multiple
different versions for people to
pre-order uh online or you know on the
Xbox store or on PlayStation Store
um but we've also gotten some questions
regarded regarding the the actual
different versions and I think we want
to just kind of like go through a few of
them so we can kind of detail out
exactly what people will end up be
getting for each of the different
versions of the game
um I know that the first version
obviously the standard edition of the
game itself
um and if you end up pre-ordering any
copy of the game uh you do get early
access to uh open Beta yeah so it
doesn't matter what version of the game
you guys as long as you as long as you
pre-order it you're gonna get early
access to the open Beta exactly and
pre-ordering the standard version of the
game you know comes with
benefits and itself of like within
Diablo 3 Diablo Immortals and cosmetics
um and of course it comes with the uh uh
a a amounts uh in and D4 and I I think
one of the coolest things is this this
World of Warcraft mount uh and I have to
give a huge shout out to uh the the wow
team here uh they absolutely killed it
I've been using this around valdraxas
myself while playing dragonfly it just
looks so so cool and uh it does come
with uh the pre-ordering the game in it
itself and if you get pre-order PC you
actually get it now and if you pre-order
on Console you'll end up getting at
launched with console when you can link
your Battlenet accounts yeah and you
know that mount is based on a character
in Diablo 4 yes uh spoilers
but yeah we we won't spoil everything
but yes it most definitely is uh and
then there is the digital deluxe version
of the game uh and we also have an
ultimate version of the game but with
the digital deluxe version in the game
uh you uh do actually get early access
to the launch of the game uh which is uh
really really awesome and it ends up
coming with an additional mount in in D4
and of course uh it also does come with
the battle pass in itself the the
premium battle pass for the game and uh
I know we have a image here for the
ultimate version of the game as well uh
which comes you know with the uh the
emote uh that's right the wings of the
uh the wing Zim out um which will allow
you to have anarius wings India in the
game show them off in town with the
remote uh the remote button yeah and
we've we've gotten uh some questions
from the community that we we wanted to
talk about in regarding the um at least
with the premium battle pass itself
um because I think there's there's
questions related to pricing of what the
battle pass is going to be but it is
going to be ten dollars in U.S US
Dollars uh in in-game currency value for
for the premium battle pass you get that
included with the digital Deluxe and the
ultimate version the ultimate version
does come with like the tier skips and
so forth
um but then uh and there's also
questions related to uh Early Access uh
for uh the digital Deluxe and the
ultimate version because I think some
people were wanting to know like oh does
that come with uh like with Early Access
does that mean I have like a massive leg
up on people and I know you guys wanted
to talk about that a little bit more
yeah so I think there are two two points
there one is um getting early access to
the to the games release that you get
through the the deluxe version of
Ultimate Edition and the thing I want to
be clear about is that the game will not
be launching in the in season one season
one will arrive weeks after the launch
of the game
and when season one starts everyone will
be starting at the same time everyone
will have an even playing field and you
know a lot of our competitive features
like leaderboards and those kinds of
things are going to show up in Seasons
so folks who get early access to the
game will get to check it out early but
you don't have to worry about
um you know any any uh Mis unfairness in
terms of Seasons yeah and I know with
like the premium battle pass and so
forth like there's like some time or
some some questions tied to like season
journey and everything
um yeah this this is a good actually I'm
glad we have an opportunity to talk
about this a little bit so there's uh I
think there's confusion about the
distinction between the battle pass and
the the idea of the Season journey and
the season journey is still in Diablo 4
in the same way that you found it in
Diablo 3 and that it's a it's kind of a
chapter based mechanic that as players
are progressing through the season able
to complete these various objectives
tied to each chapter we made some
updates the way the feature works you'll
be earning like rewards for your
character as you go through the process
for this but you'll also be earning
favor by completing chapters of the
Season journey and that favors what
drives some of the progression for the
battle pass itself so just by playing
through the game normally completing
some of these objectives and and earning
this guy earning these rewards for your
character you'll also be progressing
your battle pass more quickly which is
great because even if you don't even if
you don't buy the battle pass and there
are so many like items in the battle
pass are still available for free
they'll just get access to you as you
rank with the battle pass anyway so even
if you don't spend the ten dollars to
purchase the uh the premium battle pass
you'll still get like some minor
cosmetics and a few like uh like
gameplay like boost you'll be able to
earn during the course of that
experience but even those boosts you
know um let's say you get the
accelerated version of the battle pass
you know a few extra tier skips that
come with the the game initially when
you start playing in season one which is
again when the battle pass would
actually start yeah the uh like these
gameplay boosts have a character level
requirement attached to them in addition
to the tier requirement so just you know
if you've if you've managed to purchase
a few tiers or if you progress this more
quickly you'll still have to have a
character of the appropriate level to
make benefit to make use of any of those
things it's really really important to
us that we balance the the things that
you'd find in the battle pass the way
that they're compelling but still very
fair uh we don't want to have any
situations where players can feel that
they can pay to win yeah yeah and of
course the all of the seasonal content
is completely free and you know it's not
attached to the battle pass itself yeah
we're gonna have we're gonna definitely
do another one of these these streams at
some point just talk about like season
one and maybe Seasons more generically
and we've done some like uh we've had
like blog posts and things we've talked
about this more recently but to
reiterate like seasonal content like our
big season updates are all completely
free you know they're they're filled
with new like progression mechanics new
monsters to fight challenges new quests
and content to go and consume there's a
lot to look forward to all of that is
completely comes with the box price the
game you've already purchased yeah and
as Joseph just mentioned here like we uh
if you want to learn more about uh the
battle pass itself feel free to like
check out our blog back in August where
we kind of detail out a lot of our plans
on that and of course we we do plan on
talking more about Seasons here in the
future because uh see people are going
to want to know what season one is about
and we'll have more information as we
get closer to launching we'll try to
talk about it frankly yeah and there's
some incredible cosmetics in the yeah
yeah absolutely really cool cosmics in
the battle pass but yeah but no power
you have to prefer yep no power uh and
then uh the next big thing that I do
want to also mention of course with the
uh pre-ordering all the different games
is the collector's box and I know we've
seen a lot of chatter about this because
of like all the cool items and so forth
in it
um uh we did want to yeah we have an
image right here I mean it looks amazing
um we did want to clarify in in the
pricing of the collector's box uh right
now it uh it is priced at
96.66
and it will be available on the gear
store uh in North America EU UK and
Latin America after this dream itself
and then in Australia New Zealand and in
Korea they will have those available at
select retailers for people to actually
pre-order as well so there is going to
be options here for people uh to to
check out or purchase the actual
collector's box there is one other
question I know that a lot of people are
going have asked about like hey does
this actually come with a copy of the
game it doesn't
um this is just a collector's box of all
the items that are inside by collector
collectible items that people would want
related to D4 but this also gives you a
little bit of flexibility too because
you can actually end up getting a
standard version of the game and a
collector's box if you prefer or you can
get the ultimate version of the game and
the collector's box so you can kind of
mix and match depending on exactly what
you specifically want for for your own
needs because there's you may be like
wanting the all the the collectible
items and as opposed to all the digital
items or so from that end but what's
even cooler is that we actually have a
collector's box here yeah you do
um so we do want to show it off for the
first time look at this yeah this thing
is massive um so we're going to go
through a few of the items here this
this right here obviously is the box
with like the Gates of Hell opening up
and it actually we're trying to adjust
it for the cameras make sure people can
really see exactly professional hand
models here yeah yeah clearly we're very
good at this in particular but it's like
it's really neat that like even like it
just opens up like the gates and I think
that there's I think there's a plan to
do more heavily correct yeah without
boxing videos we're gonna we're gonna
show off some items here but then after
this stream um we are most definitely uh
hoping you guys actually check out the
uh Diablo YouTube channel because the
Diablo YouTube channel itself is uh
gonna have a full unboxing of uh all the
items and give you like a little bit of
a closer look and details and so forth
but uh we we do want to show off what we
can here for sure yeah so the first
thing we have is like one of these
prints right correct yeah there's two
different prints that actually come or
actually I guess almost three different
prints that do come with uh the uh
collector's box in itself of course some
people people may be familiar with some
of this concept art that we've actually
shown off in the past and now you'll
have your own map prints of those and
then we have another one down yeah
we're here
of this loving couple
yeah it's the it's the happy it's the
happy couple right the Nares Lilith uh
uh combo here uh of the concept art
between both the narius and chains there
yes again so cool we'll look at these
characters this way uh and then we have
the things there's things yeah we have
the uh the the veragam uh pen as well
which is really cool
um and I I you can be like terrible now
I guess terrible now in in the story
yeah it's this is so cool because uh we
had to build uh the the horadrics uh the
rod trim our key part of the story of
Diablo 4 and so we it we needed to
design
um a symbol that uh appeared in game
that was really iconic and part of their
a symbol of their order
um and it turned out to be quite
important and so we decided to make this
um this physical pin so that uh you
could kind of be part of the secret Club
that's right and there you go so you two
can join an order of secret demon
Hunters uh going across Sanctuary trying
to keep things safe exactly
um this is actually one of my absolute
favorite things here that we're about to
show I want to make sure that I actually
get the right side up I did not there we
go
I did
there we go live yeah uh yeah this is
the cloth map here of uh and what I
think the coolest part about this is
this is actually a full representation
of like the areas you'll be playing in
Diablo 4. that's right we
you know when we went to build the world
of sanctuary for Diablo 4 one of the
things we wanted to do is make sure that
the game map
um had the feel of the kind of map that
you would have
that that people made when you know they
thought maybe there were a bunch of
serpents uh in the water right and so it
was so cool to to build all of that art
for the map and then getting to actually
represent that
um as a physical object in the class map
uh is so cool and they're even more
embellishments on this map you know a
lot of the art there at the bottom uh
and all around the outside yeah and the
framing is so cool like Lila's up at the
top and like kind of Center frame there
and then of course like we mentioned
like there's there's points in the game
like skaz gland dry steps Etc that
you'll that are represented in the map
that you'll actually be able to see and
when you open up the map in Diablo 4
it's essentially this which is which is
awesome so yeah I'm just a huge D and
RPG nerd so like anytime a game has a
cloth map that comes with it like I'm
just so ecstatic people just hang that
up someplace and just put it somewhere
so I'm really really stoked we actually
have this uh and then we have there's
more there's yeah there's certainly more
uh we have the art book
which is massive yes you go Adam oh yeah
and that's you awkwardly yeah I will I
will attempt to flip through accept it
awkwardly yeah um but yeah it's got It's
got it uh in itself it's um uh a bunch
of different art that obviously the team
has been working on within the game and
so forth and uh
led by our wonderful art director John
John Mueller
um but yeah it's it's it's pretty
awesome I'm so sorry there's like super
glare isn't that glossy it's very nice
glossy Pages everyone uh it looks great
um but yeah this this thing is massive
it's super heavy uh it's hundreds of
pages here it's it's that's how thick it
is right like it's it's this is this is
a lot of art it's really cool let me
show you a little bit of it and honestly
if you've if you've like ever
pre-ordered like a collector's edition
or anything like that um from from other
blizzard titles like World of Warcraft
and everything the art books from all
the art teams here have always been so
phenomenal and that's just another so
that's not the last piece here we have
this we have the candle yes the candle
of creation here is included um this is
kind of like the the main centerpiece
for the the the collector's box in
itself this thing is really awesome the
it's pretty hefty too uh and it's great
because it's got It's double-sided here
so you can kind of choose sides
depending on what you would want Lilith
on one side and narius on the other
didn't we just do like a Twitter Poll
for like team Lilith and team and areas
we we did I will say the results blew me
away because uh I think if you ask me
like you know a month ago I would have
said Team Lilith would have been Crush
yeah yeah yeah but it ended at a 50 50
split uh so there are most definitely a
a good mixture of fans between uh uh
anarius and Lois but uh yeah the candle
itself is really cool there's a ton of
detail on the actual base as I'm
covering it with my hand yeah hand model
everyone and then of course uh it's even
got some extra details here uh on the
bottom specifically Fallen skulls you
can really see some of the uh the detail
of inaris pauldrons it's almost hard but
it's hard to show off the little detail
but thankfully we have a video later
we'll talk about some of these things
exactly images going up as well yeah and
it's got actually gotta because this
isn't a electric handle in itself this
is not like something that will just
disappear after using universe so many
uses and so forth but uh it is battery
operated there's a switch on the side
and so forth but you can then have it uh
either uh on your desk while you're
working or you know and you can flip it
from side to side depending on which
that's right which who you want to do be
in favor with Mondays for the list and
Tuesdays within ours exactly so yeah
this is the uh collector's box itself as
I said uh we will have a a unboxing on
our YouTube channels immediately after
the live stream so make sure to check
that out and uh pre-order should be
going live after this live stream on the
gear store so and that is in uh again
North America Latin America uh Europe
and the UK and then in Australia and
Korea it will be available at certain
retailers so make sure to keep your eyes
peeled for uh those specific regions and
where those details are going to be so
this is the collector's box so it's
actually really cool
um super excited I'm sad I'm not going
to be able to like immediately run over
and and pre-order in it itself because
I'm we've got to do this I gotta do this
um but we actually have a uh a lot of
other things to talk about as you guys
know uh from the the game awards and
what you probably saw in the beginning
of the live stream speaking of which I
do want to apologize for our counter it
clearly looks like like Belial has
gotten to our counter at the the
beginning of the live stream is moving a
little slow Lord of Lies most definitely
is taking advantage of it but we we did
start perfectly on time but the uh at
the game awards we did reveal uh the uh
the new cinematic yeah for Diablo 4.
yeah and um I think this would be uh
just one more a good refresher just in
case if you're jumping into the to the
live stream now or you haven't taken a
look at it I've seen it a million times
but let's take another look at the
Denarius and are nice and little trilly
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
all right
I have returned to hell
for you
that a million times and probably like
half the views on YouTube in itself
um I I am I am boosting the YouTube
viewership all by myself uh uh it
honestly is probably one of my most
favorite cinematics that you know our
sft team has worked on here it's
incredible it's incredible
um I think
um uh it'd be good to like kind of uh
help inform the community because I know
a lot of people if you're if you follow
Diablo you know who like Lilith and rasr
but then uh there's a lot of questions
related to like who is Lola who is an
artist how important are they within the
Diablo universe and
um it'd be kind of like great to give a
little primer on that yeah so you know
Diablo 4 focuses on the world of
sanctuary and it's uh the world itself
was created by anaris and lilas um you
know the Diablo the universe of Diablo
uh there's this
eternal conflict between Heaven and Hell
with the angels uh on one side and the
demons on the other side and uh and
Aries and Lilith got tired of this and
wanted to have a third a third way and
they created the world of sanctuary
where the the humans live and and Diablo
4 takes place
and sort of abandoned their
responsibility sort of right like
they're expected to continue this war
well that's certainly the the take of of
the demons and the angels both yeah yeah
absolutely
um and so you know these two characters
uh these two antagonists are a central
part of the story as As You Adventure
through the world of sanctuary the these
two Founders who do not see eye to eye
at this point uh certainly
um
our key part of of the story that uh
will unwind yeah so being able to
explore like Lilith is a character
exploringarius's characters and like
their motivations kind of what led them
to where they are now and why things are
blowing up the way they are yeah
definitely very important to the overall
story very cool to explore as well yeah
and I think like uh the Cinematic
showcases like amazing moments
especially about for an Arius I mean
he's very much you know Center Stage uh
for for kind of the first time that
people really get to see or experience
him in a Diablo game uh Beyond just like
the lore the discussions and so forth
and I think like uh just seeing his
power and and and what he represents
right there is was amazing yeah anarius
is a force to be sure
um and you know it's it's so cool to be
able to
um tell the story in a way that we can
have really multifaceted characters that
have real motivations you know like you
were saying
um but also be able to represent the the
raw power of some of these characters
like in RS like when you think about the
that shot of anarius wings you know
getting to see them uh over the army
there uh and like spreading out super
wide yeah yeah absolutely and um you
know angel wings have been uh such a
beautiful part of of Diablo games for a
long time you know I think back to
um the scene with material and the world
Stone and how his wings were represented
there the way that they can move they
have kind of this this quality that you
know I don't think I I've seen any other
other wings angel wings that are
represented quite this way they're
they're just incredible they feel very
iconic to our angels in in Diablo right
absolutely and then uh of course they're
not just uh they're not just visually
cool they're also functional
um you can see in the in the The
Cinematic we just showed he when he
lands he actually impales a number of
fallen off screen yeah with uh with his
wings yeah this is this is honestly one
of my favorite Parts where he's just
like coming down and the Fallen are in
awe and obviously he's just impaling
them and the the the the his feet
landing on the ground and like the the
amount of impact he has while doing a
soft Landing is just insane he's uh he
you can tell he's he's got something on
his mind and he clearly has an objective
wants to most definitely go towards it
uh it's it's just insane to see the
power uh that's behind him and I think
uh one of my other favorite moments is
the kind of the the the the pulse he
sends out uh that like completely
brightens up how uh all the the Fallen
are are essentially like blinded by it
but it's it's got this unique sound to
it and like a little bit of like fun
Diablo lore is that like you know uh
angels in in Diablo are beings of light
and um the sound and like the resonance
uh are all tuned to the crystal Arch and
it's almost like you're hearing his
unique sound that he actually sends out
which just causes all to fall into the
you know immediately move off uh and and
be scared of like his power and what he
brings yeah um so yeah there's there's
uh so much in regards to to the story
between uh anarius and loith and uh you
know it's it's weird to also think that
anaris is also kind of the the was
originally serving under terial
um which is obviously a very familiar
name within within Diablos so there's a
lot more to reveal that we're we're
going to be doing here over the next you
know couple months as we lead up to
launch and of course when people jump
into the game for the Diablo 4 story but
that cinematic was was phenomenal for
sure
um the next big thing that we did want
to talk about and this is a huge part
because this is actually kind of a new
thing that a lot of the the community
had may have heard of but probably don't
have a full details on and that is the
Codex of power yeah approaches power yes
the Codex of power is a brand new
feature that's coming into Diablo 4.
it's a it's a gameplay feature and Mr
Joseph Michael oh yeah yeah give us a
little bit more detail we'll talk about
this so this is one of those things I
would have loved people to talk about in
a blog a while ago but we weren't quite
ready to reveal it at that time there
was already so many things for us to
discuss so the Codex of power is this
new crafting feature that we'll bring
online in Diablo 4. I'm really really
excited about it what allows players to
do is as they are progressing through
this you know the massive interconnected
world of sanctuary they're gonna be
discovering lots and lots of dungeons as
they go and when they find these
Dungeons and they delve deep into them
at the bottom of them uh they're gonna
find uh what we call codex of power
aspects and an aspect the Codex of power
is effectively a Legendary Power that's
been in this in this very particular
form and every one of these done is the
Players progressed through in the open
world has a unique Legendary Power via
the aspect found inside of them yeah
what I what I love about that is that um
you you can create a new character and
you can you can look at some of the
powers that are available through these
Dungeons and say okay I I really want to
Target this power I'm going to go to
this dungeon get and get that power you
know so you're less dependent on like
well I hope this power drops absolutely
so there there are limitations in place
but Joe to your point that is that is
basically the intent here right is to
give players some Manner and measure of
control over the uh the nature of their
build as they're gonna are beginning to
go through those steps but the uh the
courtesy power is a way for them to
basically take these uh these aspects
and then they're able to go back to uh
to a crafter back in one of the major
cities our new occultist crafter
actually uh and when they go to the
occultists they can they can hand off
the actually we're showing right now our
sorcerer's friend has just earned aspect
of overwhelming bolts which is going to
allow her charge Bolt's ability uh to go
and fire two more projectiles of each
cast She's going for like an up close
and up close and personal melee
lightning build so this shotgun approach
for her Spenders be really really useful
more bolts more damage definitely very
good minor trade off of the Mana cost
but still what ends up being worth at
the end here we can see that the uh the
Sorceress is now heading over to the
occultist and it's going to be choosing
to imbue this aspect into one of their
existing items so she takes the uh the
item this is so you're looking a lot of
work in progress stuff that we're
looking at here because this is a this
is a live cast we'd like to be able to
show some things off uh you have an
opportunity to go and basically override
the existing Legendary Power on this and
put in the new Power they've just
collected to decodex of power so in this
way players get this deterministic way
to kind of collect a series of these
legendary powers are out there in the
game for them to find but it's not all
of them you can only find some of the
legendary Powers overall in the game
there are over 120 dungeons in the game
so this represents like a lot of really
exciting and interesting things for you
to collect as you're going through these
uh these areas
uh also uh you you don't just find
legendary powers for your class you'll
find legendary powers for all of the
class as you go and some ones that can
work in multiple classes as well and
then we think this is really cool
because every time you find an aspect
you want to uh that you put in your
codex of power uh this is now available
to all characters in that realm so
for sake of argument if we're playing in
season one you know every character that
you'd make it'll say you're playing your
sorceress first and you go find a whole
bunch of werewolf uh Druid you know
based aspects as you're playing uh when
you go and you want to build a new
werewolf character or a new Druid
character you have all those aspects to
play with from level one as soon as you
want to start kind of leveling up gear
and getting into a position where you
can make use of them so we love this
idea of like making it so it's easier to
play with other builds yeah I love to
how the you know we've really been
thinking about crafting in Diablo for
and I love how the occultist figures
into that crafting right because
um you know when we think about
legendary legendaries in Diablo 4 what
we're really talking about is the
Legendary Power
um you know and that Legendary Power can
be moved around you can use it to
upgrade rares and the occultist is sort
of the the central point of all of that
all of that crafting though that's
absolutely right so that was one big
change we add with we've talked about in
previous blogs before uh but one big
change in Diablo 4 is allowing legendary
powers of a particular type to roll on
lots of different item slots which gives
players an interesting game of deciding
where they want to play certain powers
to make the maximum system for their
builds now the Codex lets them put them
on the slots that are appropriate for
that power they can choose right but
another limitation for the Codex power
in addition to not actually having the
ability to collect all of legendary
comparison to game there's many many
more if you finders
those Powers also are always rolled at
the lowest level of power possible so it
is always better for you to go find the
legendary item that has the power that
you're interested in and then you can
choose to use that item directly or
extract the power from that item into an
aspect Crystal then go in and print into
your own item of your choosing those
legendary items you find out in the
world are always going to end up being
more powerful as a general rule yeah I
really like the idea that like no matter
what like finding stuff is still going
to lead to like you know potentially the
the the best opportunity of getting the
most amount of power but you still have
the customization ability of being able
to you know what I found this power I
would still like to use this on another
piece of gear and and and add that that
within the Codex app and you still can
yeah that's one of the things that's
great about it exactly to that point is
that you can have let's say that you are
leveling up and you get a legendary
power that you really love and you start
to sort of make your build around it
with the Codex of power you can acquire
new gear and in fact through your
Essences as well and you can extract you
can you can keep bring that power with
you so you can maintain that build so
you're not sort of losing your losing a
core part of your build as as you're
getting it here yeah and the fun thing
about this is we do want players at the
beginning to go through their class fans
they're making their skill tree
selections they're they're going deeper
and deeper into this they're making
their fun choices we do want them to be
able to still want to chase certain
other powers like for example for this
like you know kind of like Melee Focus
lightning build yeah the player here is
uh spinning it right now like there are
other powers that they they really
really want for this build like there's
a there's a lightning bolt legendary uh
that is going to allow lightning warp
legendary it's going to allow them to
have this fear basically around around
them as part of combat which as you can
see would be awesome when they're
teleporting into packs of monsters
trying to deal with damage when they're
up and close and personal there's lots
more things that for that Lightning's
work to collect as they're going through
and then hopefully find the very best
versions of those legendary Powers as
well as to find in the first place
yeah so I know with the Codex power this
is kind of a a new feature that's uh
coming in in Diablo 4 and we'll have uh
more information and more details
regarding like different uh
parts of the Codex of power and why even
the different powers you can end up
finding and so forth to imbue onto
actual weapons and and or or gear in
general here in the future plus other
mechanics and other systems that I know
people have been talking about and
wanting to know more about here in the
future but
um I did want to leave some time for
some q a because I know we've had a lot
of different questions that we've seen
pop over the community uh here in the
you know last especially in the last
week with all the announcements that
we've actually had uh uh related to
Diablo 4 and so I wanted to make sure
that we spent some time on those so we
did collect a lot of these questions
through uh different Community channels
like some of our Forums on like D3 d2r
where people are posting about Diablo 4
there to Reddit uh some of our our these
questions actually came from like social
media or even our content creators that
actually do focus in on Diablo so great
let's kind of like jump into a few of
these uh specific questions if we can so
first one we have is like what learnings
did you guys apply from other Diablo
games to Diablo 4. yeah this is a great
question because what we when you think
about the history of the Diablo IP of
all the games that have come what we
wanted to do is capture the things that
players loved about each of those
entries in the series you know and when
you think about so we we really thought
about how Diablo 1 really established
sort of this this tone of of Gothic
horror this really dark tone that was
that was quite different from other
things that you would see at the time
and we wanted to to carry that forward
and recapture that in Diablo 4.
and then
um when we look again what is what do
players love uh and hold close to their
their hearts in in Diablo too
um and we really wanted to capture that
essence of of having systems that
um
you know unfold out and have all of this
depth and ability to you know look at it
and nuance and and think to yourself
okay well I'm really going to learn all
of the details of this and I'm gonna I'm
gonna buy by by having a deep
understanding of this I'm going to
optimize my character in ways that
people who haven't don't understand
these nuances will miss and I'll feel
like oh I really am I'm optimizing that
through the system in that yeah really
the character's really like an
expression of the choices you've made
while you're leveling up and like making
interesting decisions right like that's
a great Point really really important a
lot more of that power is based on
decisions that players made along the
way power on the character yeah
itemization absolutely
um and uh and of course when we think
about Diablo 3 we think about uh the
fluidity of combat that sort of action
aspect of the action RPG
um really good kill monsters and Diablo
3. yeah and
um you know Diablo 3 added so much to
not just the the the player
um the player uh cast interactions you
know when you talk about head frames and
contact frames and all of the sort of
nitty-gritty of how that
um how that smoothness is achieved
um but also uh the effects on the
monsters monsters exploding
um various ways that monsters can die
death Death kits all of those kinds of
things and we wanted to make sure that
we represented that in Diablo 4 and and
even at a grander scale I mean if you
can't be had a fallen then you know what
have we've been doing here yeah what are
we what are we even doing exactly
exactly cool
um for the next question we have
um as I'm like dodging the camera and so
forth how does the battle pass work and
how long does it go for I know we talked
a little bit about battle pass but I
think this is actually a really good
question as well yeah it's it's a great
question so the battle pass
um will last for the entire duration of
a season and the season is three months
yep so you'll have plenty of time to
work your way through the battle pass
active players are going to have no
problem with that it's you're not going
to run out of time yeah and you'll be
earning progress like I mentioned before
about completing content in the season
Journey but also just by like killing
monsters going between dungeons
completing quests like everything you do
is be slowly earning progress towards
your uh your battle pass progress yeah
and I I know that
um uh because we we talked about season
Journey beforehand and so forth and
again that's just an opportunity for
people who even don't have the battle
pass will still have an opportunity of
actually going through a season Journey
similar to what they kind of experience
with Diablo 3 and earning things and so
forth from that specific uh uh moment as
well oh I want to call one more thing so
I think there's another question here
that sometimes is kind of asked which is
like you know how like how long am I
expected to like to play in order to
like progress through the battle pass
and like that's that's like closely
between 75 hours ish like it's in that
kind of Realm for the most part and this
is important because we don't want you
to think like you hear that there's a
battle pass it's gonna last for three
months am I expected to play every
single day for four hours for three
months like that's not how this works
really want people to engage with it at
a pace is appropriate to you and feel
that you've got the time necessary to
like really go through the whole thing
cool uh next question that we have here
is uh when does the first uh season of
Diablo 4 actually start that's right so
we'll be able to share more details
about the exact dates of when the season
starts along with more details about the
first season what kind of exciting
things you're going to get to see coming
soon but the key thing to to know is
that the game will launch in a
pre-season mode yes uh and the season
will start some weeks after that yeah
and so for those that do end up
pre-ordering again on the the digital
Deluxe with the ultimate version and
they have the Early Access period your
Early Access will be within the
preseason so it's not an opportunity to
get a leg up over other people in
regards to that first season uh for
Diablo 4. yeah I really want to make
sure people have time to like really
play through and enjoy the campaign and
see all this content before they uh they
get ready to start fresh in uh in season
one exactly
next question if I want to play Diablo 4
on PC and console do I need to purchase
the game for each platform
yes so you do need to purchase the game
for each platform that you want to play
on correct but the uh all of your
progression uh you can play between
platforms and all of your progression is
is cross-platform as well yeah and and
just to reiterate as well is that if you
do buy the premium battle pass for like
PC and you also play on Xbox for
instance uh your battle pass does carry
over because it is part of the your
Battlenet account so you'll end up
progressing both on on whichever
platform that you actually do uh play on
you don't need to purchase a battle pass
for each specific platform for each uh
each time you're playing on like
PlayStation or on Xbox and on PC that's
right
cool
uh will familiar Diablo items be
returning to Diablo 4 sorry I'm like
ducking around okay well they will Joe I
think you have some yes like I mean
there's uh there are a ton of returning
there's a so yeah a shakers come back uh
windforce is coming back uh
grandfather's coming back there's
there's a like uh like Mage fist is
coming back uh and these are unique
items so yeah I'm sorry oh yeah so the
that's a really good call out so there
are there are legendary items we talked
a little bit a little bit before they're
uh that have like elliptical powers and
then there are unique items that are
much more powerful than legendary items
are now legendary Powers control but any
slot unique items come with like a
prefix Loadout of like types of affixes
that could appear in that thing and then
what the special power is tied to the
unique item on its own and they're
really really they're they're difficult
to find they're really rare uh they're
fun Chase items and you can really build
exciting builds around some of these
things but we've tried we've taked I've
taken a lot of the ideas from these uh
these items from previous games kind of
reinterpreted them to make sure they
work with Diablo 4 but try to obtain
that thematic Essence to them like it's
been an exciting challenge to the team
to kind of go after and try to bring in
yeah we have time Diablo items returning
fan favorite a lot of new things too so
there's there's a there's a mixture of
both but you will see some returning
favorites yeah awesome
and I think that is the end of our
questions that we have there uh
specifically that we ended up grabbing I
know that we wanted to make sure that we
had enough time and so forth and uh but
I did want to uh thank you guys uh for
for joining in thank you guys obviously
for for joining us on our last live
stream but I'm gonna throw you guys
before we leave some some quick like you
know fast-paced shotgun questions
because I want to make sure that we have
all these and everything like that
sounds good I'd be curious to know
favorite class in Diablo 4 for each of
you
okay fine uh I'm sorry rogue rogue okay
so that was easy uh I I guess Barbarian
but I think in terms of specs so I could
I could just talk for the five minutes
but no barbarian right now yeah you're
right there there are so many cool
mechanics like when I say Rogue I'm
thinking I'm thinking about the idea of
being a rose and running around
like that I will say Rogue is incredibly
fun like plays like like it's if you
want a fast like agile character that
like is dancing around like everything
it doesn't disappoint it is the most I
would say that and the Necromancer
probably the two most fun and flashy uh
like characters well actually I would
say also even the Sorceress is flashy
just because of all the spell effects
and everything so again there's there's
builds I love on all the classes I I
personally I'm a druid Fanboy uh always
have been bear werewolf um actually I I
really enjoyed like the elemental specs
and so forth yeah storm is so so fun
we're gonna nerd storm everybody just
because I said something
um we don't We're not gonna just Nerf
storm don't worry then um I'd be curious
to know uh favorite enemy in Diablo 4
maybe maybe uh favorite enemy yeah uh or
enemy family enemy family wow you know I
love the uh I love what we were able to
do with the the blood casters
um there was actually an enemy in Diablo
2 under
um under the the city
that um is this vampire Caster very tall
and thin and and uh floating and we were
able to reimagine that in Diablo 4
um and it moves by uh turning into bats
and it can form out of bats so if you
get a lot of bats in one area it can
turn into one of these casters we didn't
move in Diablo 2 is bats no I maybe I
don't know like I felt I always it's so
hard to tell with like D2 because it's
like usually you find them in like
catacombs or something like that and
it's really dark and maybe they have
been and I have had no idea but yeah
yeah for me it's drowned like I just the
whole monster family for the drowned I
really really like there's something
about like the uh like these pale clammy
like Seaside monsters rising up from the
waters and one of the things really fun
is like they're really like strange and
mysterious in the world and I I really
gravitate towards that like you know
they're covered with Barnacles they've
got like all kind of like broken parts
of like like sunken sea vessels they use
in combat they they just swarm all over
the place often you'll find like you're
in slick areas where it's raining when
you have to actually encounter them like
they're they're a super funds A group of
monsters to fight they've got some neat
a lot like they're like they're Brew
like has like really really neat
abilities you have to kind of trying to
like Dodge and avoid they're very
dangerous so yeah they're my favorite I
think right now nice nice
um what's a fun fact you guys
encountered while developing Diablo 4.
fun fact developing dial before
I'm gonna throw out a jail life so a fun
fact I learned while developing Diablo
4. uh that it is
uh in very very important while we're
allowing players to like make a lot of
choices and they're thinking about the
way they like make a really interesting
character for themselves that we unveil
that kind of slowly initially otherwise
we have a tendency to like get people
like really like scared about making
choices and uh they kind of climb up
which is obviously not what we want
people to like be able to engage with
these kinds of features so I it's maybe
not like a fun fact but I think it's
very interesting went through a lot of
iterations to get to the right place I'm
really happy with where we landed
yeah I now I have to give a serious
answer no I'm sorry I should give him
like I should have given some other fun
fact no no no I think it's better okay
you know I think uh we went through
we went through a lot of um iteration on
the uh the First skit when you start out
in in the very beginning of of Diablo
for
um for a while you started with
um one of your classes um left click
basic skills and we had a lot of trouble
with having that skill that we'd chosen
for you feeling like well I guess I
should build a spec around this because
it's just you get you start with it
you're familiar with it
um and it sort of constrained your
ability to explore the the skill tree
yeah so like it's like like if sore
start with like Firebolt for example
like a lot of people that were testing
would just make fire like spec Sorcerers
they wouldn't think about like trying
other other skills so so we ended up
going with a basic uh ability we ended
up adding
fairly late in development a basic
attack that you start with so that when
you get your first level up you actually
get to choose okay well which which spec
do I want to start with and of course
you can respect within the skill tree
um pretty freely so yeah and I yeah I
remember that when it was originally
like that and thankfully we we test
internally and so forth we get our own
feedback from from within the team of
what people are actually doing from that
end
um the of course and last last but not
least the most controversial question uh
Team inarias or team Lilith
team in Arias even though I'm wearing my
Lily that's actually that's actually
really funny um I guess I guess still
team Lilith I think I'm still talking I
think I'm still team off yeah I split I
I won't break the tiebreaker here we
will keep the pole trying to stay very
neutral I will stay neutral here I I I
will I will choose that team team bail
there we go it's behind me it's perfect
it's perfect
um great well I think that uh kind of
wraps up our time here today on the uh
developer update stream
um I do want to note uh that you know we
thank everyone again for tuning in for
our first uh developer update stream
this has actually been kind of uh a
crazy process of getting a a studio up
uh back in the building and I'm happy
that we can call this home for our our
streams going forward
um we do have a lot of Diablo activities
that are going on that we've uh
announced or will announce here I'll say
in a second yeah uh for for the whole
entire franchise um if you are a big fan
of Diablo Immortal or a player Diablo
Immortal we just had a huge update for
1.7 uh uh come out yesterday uh it's
massive it's probably our biggest update
yet so I do recommend checking it out
lots of um uh big narrative moments and
and whole new areas for that kind of
expand the campaign in Diablo Immortal
as well as uh a lot of quality of life
features that the community's been
asking for so been hearing a lot of
great positive feedback and we're
excited that um that's out right before
the holidays and then d2r earlier this
week we announced 22 Nights of terror
it's an in-game event that uh
essentially changes uh the the game
every single day and it's kind of a
surprise think of it like a Diablo
Advent calendar you could say uh so that
actually started earlier this week and
for Diablo 3 fans we actually have a new
holiday event this is a brand new event
uh for uh Diablo 3 that I'm really
excited to be working hard on that yeah
yeah our D3 team has been working really
hard and they're working really hard on
the next season and uh we'll actually be
revealing that tomorrow on uh on the
blog so make sure to tune in for that
and we'll also have news related to
um of course the dark Neo Tristan which
happens every single year for Diablo 3
and when that will be occurring so make
sure to check out Diablo 3.com from that
side
um any parting words from you guys yeah
you know I really wanted to thank
everyone for tuning in today and
following us throughout the year it's
been a big view for us as I was saying
earlier a ton of work getting all the
content into the game setting us up for
next year setting it up setting us up
for release
um we've got a lot of bugs to fix in the
the new year we've got uh to make sure
that our server architecture and
infrastructure is uh in good shape for
for our of course our betas coming up
and um uh and our release as well so
some work ahead of us and we have a lot
of exciting stuff to share uh next year
as well um through some of these some of
these live streams more of these live
streams
um but uh you're not going to hear from
us for a little while uh because we're
all going to take some time off to be
with our families for the holidays and
really take a break from uh you know
from Diablo 4 just just not think about
The L4 for a little bit a restful uh uh
holiday period for the team for sure
sometimes we have like builds up people
like sort of like log in and continue to
play like it not this time we're killing
all the builds for the holidays and
forcing everyone to not be not Beyond
yellow for a little while be good
any parting words uh yeah no shout outs
to the uh the various uh Diablo updates
we have coming down the road I recommend
everyone take some time to play some
world of the warcrafts because uh
dragonfly is rad really fun but uh for
the community itself I think that this
has been a huge year for the Diablo team
much as Joe has already said we're
really excited we'll just finally start
sharing more and more about what like
where the game is at and like where what
we've been thinking about and what we
value
um it's been awesome talking to press I
really can't wait to just keep this
conversation going I think this is going
to be the best thing for everybody both
on both for the dev team build to get
this feedback and like hear the sorts of
things that you're interested in also
make sure that we're regularly talking
to you so you know what to expect and
you can you know what we're kind of
where our heads are at so I I am I'm
really excited about like that so thank
you for sticking with us this long and
hopefully everyone enjoy the things that
happened over the course this last
couple months yeah and like I said this
is kind of the new way that we're going
to be communicating out to the community
through these developer update streams
uh we're super excited for them
especially as we get into next year we
have way more information to review
including details next year early next
year about the the open beta and when
that will actually be starting as well
so again thank you everyone for tuning
in and I just want to say happy holidays
and we'll see you guys next year from
the the Diablo team thanks again